does human consciousness in some way
determine
not just the presence of the UFO but
does it play a role in what how a person
perceives it or how a person what kind
of experience a person might have in
connection to that phenomenon I mean for
instance there will be witnesses to the
same phenomenon but their experience of
it is each person perceives it in a
different way they'll describe it
differently they'll have a different
kind of experience
what is that about is that because of
the consciousness of the of the human
being that's in the presence of this
thing even though the thing itself was
just something out there
you know it's it's like um
and also sometimes people have an
encounter and then they develop these uh
abilities you know not just Clairvoyance
or telepathy they develop kind of more
psychic powers or however you want to
describe it after that as if they have
their Consciousness has been impacted in
some level we don't understand you know
they're able to perceive more uh on the
on the on the realm of the Paranormal
than they were before
uh so
and then there's questions about whether
it's connected to
the Outlook what people consider to be
uh the afterlife where we go when we die
um people are studying that question a
lot it's it's
um it's mysterious and it has and then
the whole question of Time how we Define
time
comes into play I mean um there's a show
uh there's a series on Netflix called
Dark
I don't know if you ever see if you've
ever seen it it's a German series but
it's it's really profoundly deals with
the question of time travel and it has a
lot of messaging in that show that I
think relates to
how we perceive this phenomenon and What
the deeper level of it is
and so you know you can just keep going
peeling back the layers and peeling back
the layers and you go to places with
this that
just expand your mind and you can't
contain them in a certain